carefully when the statement's been made
back in the day sisters you should come
and put your mics on and everything you
know
looking amazing used to make uh
[Music]
we were called perverts been doing this
for 20 and something years
and i've never ever ever been called
that in my entire life
and this really hurt me brothers and
sisters
it hurt me to hear that when i told my
shoyuk about what happened
they said we are ready to refute this
man
this journey this road that i travel on
it all seems crazy over the years i
picked up thousands of tiger lungs
inspired by my story from a juvenile
where my clothes had holes in them and
my afro was picky
to the nighties moschino and versace
no laces in aurora cheese new millennium
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are wed
inshallah
welcome to this uh spontaneous video
alhamdulillah um
but before i start one praise allah the
most most for the most trust or praise
is glory and gratitude belong to him
for the works that we do in general uh
brother sisters to me
i find um i find great importance
in defending muslims honor now i'm not
saying this to
i don't want nothing from you i don't
want praise from you but i find that
to defend somebody's honor is very
important and it's something that we
turn a blind eye to a lot
it's very very important for us uh
somebody who
may have done something wrong or may
have not regardless
the one who's done something wrong if
he's repented a lot of the times people
what they do is they're like no
it should be slaughtered finishing me
and they he should not exist anymore
people go to that extreme and then
there's other extreme where people are
like no
don't don't hold them to account we're
saying let's meet in the middle and it's
very important for us to do that problem
sisters and throughout my videos i'm
sure
you guys have realized that i tried to
do that and i tried to do it by
implementing the islamic
sharia law yeah in the context of how it
should be dealt with
uh and i read books on this you know um
book on
islamic jurisprudence i have my own
teachers who educate me
who uh guide me and um
that it's very very important for us to
do that and sisters and i did that with
shahid
when this whole fiasco happened before
as well um i done it
very recently when a certain brother was
being accused of actually
um drugging and raping sisters the
accusations
and we do not say they are true or false
what we say is islamically
that i'm not a judge i'm not nobody but
if there's no evidence we can't do
nothing about that but anyways
just to give context so brotherhood
salaam alaikum
i didn't know you're 50 years old you
look you look like you're
i would say 40 latest martial arts
yeah so i'm going to call you uncle
jawad uh um
um now this is something that we've been
obviously um
you let's talk a bit about you what do
you do what's what is it that
i am a tv presenter why should i do
children
shows i'm a fundraiser yeah i die i give
darwin
to allah i've been doing it for about a
bit more than 20 years
alhamdulillah and i hope i can do it
a bit more than 20 years more in shock
inshallah i've been you know out in the
public known as uncle
jawad like you've said you know done
children shows
from back in the day uh really feel for
the ummah
you know i used to be in the
thick of the the bad stuff yeah but took
me out of that
changed me around and used my talent to
do something a bit more positive a lot
more positive
especially for the um out there the the
the youth in charlotte
you know um and uh of course inshallah
i've enjoyed it
it's been beautiful come a long way
mets beautiful people met beautiful
really nice people mashallah
from anti-gs to martial you know
families
a lot of children in charlotte been in
the limelight
you know done a lot of stage work excel
and all these things
been to malaysia for dawah you know
working with the likes of
uh mercy mission and alakotha and you
know working on
ramadan tv back in the day and
alhamdulillah my career has come
right up to now still doing stuff on
iman channel as well as
bm tv a lot of people might see me on
like beyond
bmtv and penny appeal uh uh and
enchilada
you know my intention is really to you
know do my part
for the umma you know alhamdulillah and
i've enjoyed it all the way you know
really love love doing what i do i'm
sure you do you know like myself as well
like i'll be honest uh when it comes to
the doubt a lot of people think
i'm doing dawah mainly for like others
but i'll be honest with you i think the
dao was seen keeps me in check uh i'll
be honest if i wasn't doing dawah i may
be doing
other sins so the dawah alhamdulillah me
carrying on
keeps me in check yes so that's the
reason i do it and
i'm thinking to myself if i was
personally to make a mistake
if that was taken away from me depends
on the mistake of course let's let's be
real if it's
something that's grave then there's no
excuse about that but if it's something
that you know
it's a genuine mistake could be
happening etc for that to be taken away
from me
it would cause more damage you know it
depends on what it is
so i was hearing these things about
a month ago ramadan like just after i
can't really remember
um so i didn't really i saw parts of it
people were messaging me a lot of
sisters were messaging me oh brother
and there was a lot of as usual i hit
this all the time i don't know why i'm
getting this um
oh you know you always attack the
sisters and i'm like oh sister
if you watch my videos i'll be honest if
there's anyone that should be
complaining as a brothers
because i give them a hard time more so
maybe you're not subscribed to my
channel and if you're not success please
subscribe now
because i do not discriminate i do not
and and i see the hypocrisy
in certain uh brothers or the community
as a whole when a sister does something
shows you know
when a pink color hijab uh the stress
they put on the sisters
so i try to be just and i'm i think i'm
one of the first youtubers who've done a
video on men's hijab tutorial
how a man should conduct himself and
it's very important if
one of the one who was the most modest
so i tried to be just well
i was getting a lot of messages oh this
happened what's going on i didn't
understand those video clips i didn't
really see it
there was certain bits that they showed
um which i didn't pay attention to
but before we start this video you
showed me and there's something that
caught my attention
should we go straight to the video okay
understand what's happened there
and let's analyze it and then let's come
to the full context of what's happened
because i genuinely
want to know what happened yeah i want
to hear from you what happened
let's take it and learn lessons from
this inshallah so let's watch the video
if you
have the video on your phone in allah
brothers sisters um
we're going to watch them inshallah they
will fund reason with brother faz
and uncle jawad um they were fundraising
and uh just to give context look i'm a
fundraiser
um where one brother sami's house may
allah
beautiful brother and i would love to do
it with you in the future as well
inshallah
um so the thing is you're gonna
understand
understand some dynamic dynamics into
the tv scene
that you haven't before which i'm going
to elaborate let's watch it first in
short so this is the clip
the website is globalone.org
so from this moment onwards it's cut
it's coming
the the the the feed is cut it's curly
but the camera is recording the camera's
recording okay yeah
how did this get public by the way
unfortunately
one of the editors yeah he didn't do his
job properly
okay yeah where they usually cover and
an advert comes in there
okay uh because but that's that's for
the facebook stream
yeah the tv stream is cut it's cool but
for the facebook street facebook stream
it's carrying on right now that's right
let's carry on but it's not
it's not only that as well okay yeah
it's uh the youtube streaming yeah
it's carrying on a youtube channel
because it's it's
as well yes and the thing that went out
was a pre-recording okay
so what we would do we would do a show
yes they would film it
yeah and then the following day
they would play it sorry through night
through the night oh okay yeah
this was actually seen around about uh
before fajr time before
okay we were going to set our fast okay
all right
really what happened i was at home
because i go home and like many of us we
stay up
and we do the prayers and set off fast i
was at home
munching on my cereal and this came on
and i said stuff for
get it off quick i picked up my phone
rang the engineer said get it off get
off quick
because it's going out live you know it
wasn't pre-recorded
okay yeah and uh this is this is what
went out okay so uh oh this was done in
secret so so while you've seen this a
lot of people there'll be
some people gonna be watching somebody
like oh you're upset
that it became public no let's watch
carefully because we're gonna analyze
what's happening step by step let's play
it inshallah
all right
is
okay are you speaking to a gin who's
pete pete is one of the controllers in
our ears
because we got feedback okay so you're
speaking to pete in the back
no okay yeah i'll be presenting one of
the things that really irritate me
is sometimes they forget to move and it
gets very confusing
and you would see me on iman channel
many times i'll be like brothers in the
back
i can hear you i do it on purpose
because usually supposed to be the
screener right that's right i'm sorry
i'm just like yeah brothers thank you
yeah i can hear everything you're saying
because it's your focus when i'm doing
it with sami i can't hear like if
somebody's talking i'm sorry i'm just
like
yeah yeah yeah and he thinks i'm
listening to i'm not listening to him
because i've got someone in my ear
so imagine guys someone speaking how i'm
speaking to you you've got a device
right in your
ear where you hear and there's like a
little
man voice where it cancels out
everything yes
so you're speaking to pete but there's
there's three
engineers so there's three of them yeah
yeah yeah and when they and when they
don't move and they're talking within
their self
you're hearing the echo of yourself and
them talking you guessed it so you're
speaking to pete
i'm talking to p okay good so just to
give you guys context promises as a
presenter that is something that really
irritates and also
you are trying to focus in two plays at
one time now this is very
i want people to just i want people to
really really
understand this point because it's going
to make us understand and puts things
into context
of what happens after but yeah you want
to see can i just say as well you know
brother and sisters
uh when you look at and i know ali is
going to cover it now when you look at
the screen and you see this footage
you see two of us in the studio yes but
there's five
there's five of us in that conversation
yeah and like ali just said
three in my ear yeah yes and faz
sitting next to me yeah okay so we're
going from exactly let's carry on let's
go
some water please
okay can you give me some context to
that because
the times that we live we live in a
cancer culture by the way yeah and we
live in a
a society where you moving whatever you
do it's
you're scrutinized there's someone
watching this sadly that may have come
across as sexist
to them i'm so because that's the
society we didn't well can you give us
more context of why did you mention
sisters why not brothers why didn't you
say you know what before
it was brothers who used to come and cut
watermelons and do our mics etc
why sisters did this this is very
important are you did you say
this because subconsciously in your head
you believe sisters belong in the
kitchen
or did you say this because this is a
reality that happened
it's a reality what happened how because
soprano
when i first started working for bmtv um
the sounds man wasn't a man okay the
control uh people men in the room
weren't men
they were sisters they were all sisters
okay and they were
they were like my they were they were
young sisters like in their 27's
i'm like their uncle i treat them like
my daughters yeah and uh we
you know we had a very nice uh
relationship in there
and uh subhanallah when you know you've
been sitting there for a while
these sisters martial are they're
they're lovely beautiful sisters
what they would do they would come in
and they would martial are
make us cups they'll say uncle do you
need a drink
you know subhanallah they would
subhanallah they would bring watermelon
for us you know subhanallah and of
course
uh the soundsmen and the sounds it was a
sounds woman a sister martial
bless her she used to come and put uh
mike on us
so much so that when i used to do before
i used to go on
out on live shows i used to film them on
my phones
little videos and then i would put them
out on my facebook yeah
and there was one particular time my
sister she was miking up all the
brothers yeah yeah
and i said right watch us tonight in
shadow teller live we're coming on
blah blah blah blah and the sister she
knew that i was filming
she turned her back because she didn't
want to be seen
okay you understand yes okay because she
was putting mics on us
right okay so so so when you said
sisters used to do this yeah i
understand some sisters come from point
of view where brothers have made them to
feel that they're nothing but you know
they should work in the kitchen etc
and i think what they did is they
misconstrued what you said and they made
it
they thought that you're trying to say
oh sisters serving us oh coffee and tea
and watermelons and mines
so if that was brothers let's suppose it
wasn't sisters but he was working with
brothers
would you of you say sisters or would
you say brothers no sir because that was
a reality yes okay that's context to me
yes yeah that's context i have to be
just here
i'm not here uh uh uncle joey to uh take
your uh
side or not i'm here for justice i'm
here to defend honor i believe if it
requires defending
and to scrutinize it with all respect if
it needs to scrutinize
um so one thing i'll make very clear i'm
totally against sisters working
mike this i believe i believe it
shouldn't happen that's my personal take
on it
yeah um it's it's to me it's like i just
want to make that clear because i don't
want people to think
yeah um me personally i wouldn't want
noises to do my mic
if the sisters are working there look
i'm not saying they can't yeah if they
made to your coffee but i'm personally
not interacting with the sisters of his
agenda
that's personal to me and i believe
that's what islamically should be done
but i understand certain situations et
cetera that's it i'm not even going to
go right
i i can i say this i i i hold
similar ways because uh these chat this
channel knows
yeah yeah that uh sitting with sisters i
don't do that
yeah yeah you know if they asked me to
sit with a sister i said sorry with all
due respect
and i have a lot of respect for my
sister yeah but i just feel a little bit
uncomfortable to do that
you know that's why if you've ever seen
me on that channel you'll never see me
sit with sisters not because i
put my sisters down now i have a lot of
respect for my sisters you know i'm old
school
brothers and sisters i'm from back in
the day muslim yeah
uh where you know they're like our
daughters you know and
if you need a mahram you need a mahram
yeah but i know in media there are
certain channels that
they say you know because it's in the
public eye and all those things
fair enough you know but and
and because of that there are brothers
that do sit with sisters
on certain channels yeah alhamdulillah
but i know there are some presenters
that ask the channels this is my stance
yes can we work with that
no problem exactly okay and that's what
they would do if they
needed for for for example if they
needed sisters on the couch
yeah yeah they would put they would say
take jawad off put the sisters on
let them do their spills and we love to
have the sisters because sisters relate
with sisters
yeah yeah and then uh and me uh you know
you you're gonna be talking about
you know certain things that we need to
give to our sisters in
the packs to syria and all that stuff
sisters are gonna know better than me
yeah no of course definitely definitely
this context look i've been to certain
charities where we've gone abroad
they've had sisters there to
look i'm here to do my bit they're not
on camera i try
i'm staying they'll be on camera and
even there i would i would tell you
about certain stuff like
you can see when you know it doesn't
work but that's a different topic let's
move on
now something something what happens
next let's watch it because i think it
turns um a bit sour at this moment of
time with
something rather fast said so let's yeah
let's see that in sha allah
very important here as well yeah that
that
what's going on now is with five people
yes okay it's not just me and faz
talking
yeah because i'm i'm talking to them in
my ear and in faz
he's got it in his ear as well so all of
us are in this conversation
okay yeah so yeah can you go a bit back
please
okay what i see here is you you have no
you're not acknowledging look i'll
repeat again i want people to see this
as well yeah
yeah i'm i'm genuinely trying to be fair
here here
you back in the day guys i want you to
pay close attention to
brother jawad yeah when that statement
is made yeah and by the way this theme
is absolutely wrong
there's no i'm not here it's very clear
it's wrong i'm not going to i don't it's
it's
it's unacceptable it's wrong uh
it's as simple as i just want to put
look at brother joad
very carefully when the statement has
been to come and put your made on and
everything you know what i mean looking
amazing
used to make bring the water here uh
cheers there's always in a minute
call call lala you're in five and get
this in bbc
so the thing is look you i'm assuming
you know what he's talking about when he
made that statement like like in general
before
not from the angle if someone said that
if i said that that very statement he
said now
i didn't under understand that first by
the way when he said i didn't know what
he was talking about
because i genuinely didn't know that
what that meant but
today i know what that means yeah if
somebody said that if me and you are
filming now and
and another third person came and said
that i have to have two kind of
responses
laugh with him or say don't say that
brother
that's that's wrong i'm gonna say that
you don't do any of them you don't
you don't if you don't laugh neither do
you just
so you tell me if i'm wrong
but is someone speaking in your ear yes
brother okay
yes yeah and allah is i'm asking you
yeah allah is watching is someone
speaking in
here yes okay because what you did there
it reminds me when i'm doing an appeal
with sami and sami is talking or whoever
i'm doing it was talking and i'm just
i'm just i'm listening but i'm listening
to my ear yeah
because the action that i saw from you
is you didn't you didn't laugh with it
you didn't say oh man that was rude or
don't say that there was nothing he was
just like
no there was there was that now as far
as i know
you lost your job okay i personally
believe this is my own personal
uh belief what you did about the
watermelon and stuff like i'm so sorry
for someone to lose their job because of
that let's suppose argument's sake let's
say you meant it in a sexist way which
you didn't let's suppose you did
it doesn't it doesn't mean you should
lose your job no way
and secondly you made it very clear that
you said sisters
actually did those things not because
they're sisters but it was actually
sisters that were doing those things if
it was brothers i would have said
brothers
so coming from that context that
explanation enough
is it's enough for me to say that you
should never
lose your job when it comes to what
brother fah said
yeah may allah forgive him because we
know that i've been heard that yes he's
trying to better himself and this was a
source of him look everyone has their
means etc
may allah make it is on him but what he
said was absolutely wrong
absolutely wrong and we understand the
outrage of the sisters 100 percent
however this doesn't mean that you
totally vilify and
finish the guy off in the context of
when you see him he's no no i'm so sorry
if somebody's repented
and they changed their ways and they
acknowledged for you to carry that until
the guy and says the great is
grave is wrong it's wrong
what he said is i'm so sorry very wrong
very wrong
my facial expression is enough but to
say it's even injustice on him to say
that anytime you see him you're like
this i'm so sorry you repented you
changed your ways
fell okay you working with that's the
organization that's
at the discretion of the companies want
to work with you know that's a different
situation
but to treat him like he's lower than
you subhanallah i'm so sorry he might
even be better he might be better than
me
his repentance might be so sincere he
must have changed he may have changed
his way so much
that while life has more beloved to
allah than anything that i can do
let's make that very clear so let's not
look down on individuals even look
at themselves i have i've done nothing
i'm sorry what lie allah is i've gone
podcast with them sunday yeah
well if there's a moment that i think
i'm better than adam sally
never do i think oh i'm better than you
how you did this opportunistic male that
protect me because i know how allah you
look for the fault of a believer
allah will find your fault in your house
you know your house in your house you
think when no one can touch you while
will find your thoughts don't be people
and
individuals where you hunt for people's
mistakes i can't wait
look at the disease in your heart look
at the disease in your heart that you're
looking for
let me find him oh this mistake so i
believe it's absolutely injustice
that you are losing your job because of
a statement you made which is true
sisters used to bring watermelons or um
bring teas because as respect not
because they're your servants because
that was their part of their job if it
was a brother that was a brother's job
you would say brothers used to come and
serve watermelon and make us tea
and do a mix up you you you spoke a
reality
i don't believe you should lose your job
hands down
but secondly the statement that he's
making while
allah is my witness to me i'm a
presenter you guys might not know that
put yourself in our situation there is
someone speaking to you in your ear and
you've got
they've got your full focus you can't
listen to two people look have you ever
tried listening to two people who are
speaking to you
let alone having a little like a little
man in your ear
literally talking and your full focus is
there from what i can see from there
somebody was talking to you he was
talking and he was like
you didn't hear him and you didn't
acknowledge why
the camera is there the camera's online
the visual footage shows
you didn't acknowledge yes you didn't
laugh with it you didn't rebuke him
nothing it was just
that's right that's how i saw that three
four five seconds off
what was that like what happened did you
black out no what happened so
from that angle what i want to now move
on to quickly
is we can establish right now that
that's a private sin
yes brother i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
that is a private scene
sin as good as this let me tell you
something let's suppose now the camera's
camera's rolling yeah but i don't want
this footage to be in there and i say um
what can i say let's say um uh this
probably not this brother i think it's
it's breathtaking so bad that's back
biting
if this is now recorded and i didn't
want it in there and i put it out there
by accident that is a private sin
that by accidentally went public and the
ones who take opportunity out of that
you are in a massive sin you know why
because what you've done is
you've took a private sin that is done
let's suppose we all privacy and please
don't tell me anything
some of you guys private sins in your
house please
please yeah the sharia doesn't come into
your household in the shed in the sharia
two people can be homosexual be doing
homosexuals in the house
nobody can come this is this generation
i don't know if it's authentic
going into a man's house where he's
drinking and the man rebukes somebody
says look this is my house you are
sinning not me
you are violating by coming into my
household to
yeah so even if this didn't happen this
is what the sheriff said you can't go
and start spying on people and
looking what was what we told you knock
on the door ask permission before you
come in
so if that happens now who can you tell
me this i'm hearing
actually people of knowledge who
actually
let alone covered this they took it and
were using words like
pervert who are these individuals who
took opportunity at this because to me
please i can be educated please tell me
how is that right that a private scene
that's made public
the least you can do is you know what
don't say nothing doesn't matter don't
bring it to light
you're adding fire oh they did this et
cetera and some people i'm not saying
these checks
some people tried to be heroes yeah so i
came to the rescue oh
you're damned you're finished you're the
subhanallah don't be a hero
this is fake piety yes yes so who
who took opportunity of this there's a
particular shake his name is uh
abu isa from al-maghrib yes i know
i don't know personally but i've seen
the yeah what happened this
uh this video which was
edited yeah and the person who'd done
the editing was a pretty sinister thing
there's a big agenda behind all this
that the public don't
know about and we're here tonight to you
know here today to to bring some of that
out in the light right
um basically the video that went out
that everyone saw
yeah um
that video was taken yeah it was put on
about easter's website yeah and
he basically without he's a man of
knowledge yes
yes and he should have come and
addressed us he should have took
us aside and he should have asked us
you know about this and then gone
through the proper islamic way of doing
it
yeah but unfortunately it wasn't like
that he just jumped on the bandwagon
took the video put it on his facebook
and i think his twitter as well yeah uh
and i went on there and has he's got a
massive forum yeah
and uh we were we were called perverts
you know we were called all these words
perverts where you know brother and
sisters i've been doing this for
20 and something years and i've never
ever ever been called that in my entire
life
and this really hurt me brothers and
sisters
it hurt me to hear that because i have
no
i do i'm not like that i'm all for it
i love my brothers and sisters well
until a day i die
and this is a man of knowledge when i
told my shoyuk about what happened
they said we are ready to refute this
man he has gone the wrong way about it
and for abu issa out there i have even
been told by a sheikh
that you should be giving us an apology
for what you've done
because this is this is terrible no one
has come to me
and we made a you know what another
thing we made
look when this video came out brothers
and sisters
the third day in ramadan it came out
right
and i well i tell you the truth the
third day in ramadan it came out right
um what was the response of the ummah
because you got to remember we're doing
ramadan appeals right at the end of
ramadan
the charity global one made about 1.2
million pounds for charity now
the impact that i am in now losing my
job and i got sacked and my name
is being ridiculed and all these things
yeah
how come that wasn't
on the third day in because the umma
forgave us
because we came out yeah and i'll talk
about myself yeah
faster myself we were told to make an
apology video
right and we apologize the ummah forgave
us
because the response from the third day
in up to 1.2 million
at the end of ramadan we would have got
50p every day
they would have turned this off they
would all this ridiculing
that everyone was texting and typing
yeah would have been on the third day
but because there's a real sinister
uh bit of information underneath this
that the public don't know about
before they before it got to the world
cup the 27th night
where it was put out viral and it was
tampered with
and you know people spoke about it there
was a particular individual we'll give
his name when the time is right yeah
his people they took the video they
played about with it and then they put
their spiel underneath
it and then they held it brothers and
sisters
we we made an a national apology
on live television we asked the ummah
for forgiveness we asked the charity for
forgiveness
we we ask the channel for forgiveness
right and i'm i'm me myself jawad sawad
asks forgiveness for for a crime that i
haven't even done
just by honoring my sisters
i'm telling you the truth i have been
i've been named in shame for something i
haven't even done brothers and sisters
we are meant to be the um of mercy
exactly the thing is this you didn't say
this statement
subhanallah yeah like brother fat said
it yeah and it's like i said before it's
totally unacceptable and that's the
reason why i don't believe sisters
should do
any mics or coming i'm so sorry yeah
it's it's
it's just not a good mix it's as simple
as that i believe that and that is
evident
what makes that joke and the thing is
you didn't see it
this one trying to understand you did
not see it and from that video it's very
clear
you wasn't even listening to him i'm so
sorry guys please if i'm wrong
tell me otherwise what's he doing what
is it is he having a blank moment is he
daydreaming what's he doing he's not
laughing
he's not uh correcting him what's he
doing just brothers and sisters
and we should assume the best as well so
to me it's very clear a private sin
has been made publicly okay and then
you've got people of knowledge taking
coming on board and calling
pervert subhanallah
listen let's assume the best and say you
know brother faz
he it was the first time he ever said
that to call someone a perfect means is
he's in action he does perverted stuff
all the time
yeah you can't go and it's to kind of
name someone something just because
you saw them doing that very thing at
that specific moment of time it's
disgusting what he said was wrong
absolutely wrong if that was his own
sister he knows very well i don't need
to go down that route if you do a sister
he apologized him having his job that's
at the discretion of them
but for you to lose your job with
something that you didn't say
and it's clear from the footage that you
didn't even acknowledge
brothers and sisters is absolutely
unfair um and subhanallah
it's and you provide for your family you
know and then there is something that
you love doing i know
if someone took dow away from me i'll be
lost i'll generally be lost like in the
context of
what do i do this might be why i woke up
with what slept with
that's what i ate you know
it's very very hard brothers and sisters
so we're asking
that's the final let's be people of
mercy yeah especially to brotherhood if
he hasn't done it he was
just because he was at the the crime
scene that's that's why i got a
sac brother an association
you know the actual chairman the actual
chairman of clover one
allah bless her she was very nice to me
yeah
but it's part of committees committee
members yeah and
uh some of the committee members they
said because of association
yeah which is absolutely silly
because you know because you're at the
crime of the scene
and you were walking past you've done
the crime as well
you know which is absolutely silly uh
uh he said another thing about abu issa
as well
like i said he didn't even have the
audacity a man of knowledge
didn't even have the audacity to get in
contact with us yeah
and he didn't another person i want to
complain about as well
is five pillar because five pillars they
put the statement up there as well
uh saying that we did you know did all
this
and nothing was uh yeah i know that i
know them closely i don't know if
brother dilly was aware
maybe because you know it was out there
in the public and they just put it on
yeah okay
fair enough fair enough right but the
the most sinister of out of them
out of all of them is this uh ahmed
zubir
yeah and i know ahmed to be here yeah i
know him back in a day yeah myself from
farooq we used to do fundraising
for him he's from derby yeah okay and
we had a very nice relationship and you
know i know things about i know things
about him i'm not here to
slay of i i just want everyone to know
today
there are things i know but i fear a lot
of brother sisters you hide the
sins say hadith you hide the sins of
your brother or
sister one hadith allah will hide them
on the day of qiyamah
allah you make 70 excuses for your
brothers or sisters
allah will do it for you hadith hadith
anyone who defends the honor of his
brother or sister allah will save their
face
from jahannam do i read these things do
we read these things as lip service
did i go through one ear and come out
the other think about johannam
69 times hotter than the hellfire who uh
than the worldly fire who wants to go
there
so you're gonna look for those deeds
yeah that's gonna make you escape that
place
and that's why i love darwin that's why
i love moving with these brothers this
is why we are here
to save us from that place isn't it yeah
so i'm i'm saying here today right this
this this this guy
uh ahmed zubir yeah what did he do
he basically even made
a video on his facebook
uh around about this time he went out
public and he
basically he's got a he's got a beef
with penny appeal and bmtv
okay right they've got a private thing
it's been going on for a very long time
i don't know nothing about it i just
work for a channel
just doing the fundraising i think about
orphans and widows
i don't know about all their politics i
i don't get into that stuff brother and
sisters right
but he's got a beef with a channel yeah
and
you know he just he's out to get him
and his people are the ones why i'm
sitting here today
because they took this video and they
tampered with it and they gave their own
spiel and they put it out
and even on the show when we were doing
the after we made the apology
he was getting people ringing up in the
show saying oh this is appalling how can
you brothers
even sit there and running down sisters
right
and we told we you know faz he
made an apology he said you know these
things were happening it all happened in
secret
yeah the editor didn't do his job right
and we got chucked under the bus we even
made a
a apology video you know to the to the
brothers and sisters
but this this brother he made an a
separate video
and uh i just want to say this right
brother sisters because in islam
in islam allah subhanahu says and
majestic we we created you from
different tribes
different from different nations and
different colors
right but this brother is calling me a
black african
you know what he's got to do
black lives matter broth they do right
and i'm saying this
why because in this in this
uh industry yeah some of these brothers
they got these traits some of them i'm
not saying everyone
but we're mostly mean and color means
nothing i'm not going down that road
what i'm going to say is yeah this
brother
allah forgive me i don't even want to
call him my brother because my
my character in islam is sacred all of
these things are sacred yeah
and the way that he uh ahmed zubaid
for allah brother because what you have
done
by taking my name through the cleaners
and all this work i've been doing for 20
years
of helping i've raised over 100 million
pounds if not more
for charity all of it has come to a
standstill now
all those orphans in the future that i
want to help
may be hanging you know because of
something that you've done some beef you
had with a with a channel
yeah you named and shamed and chucked me
under the bus
right and i i've helped this brother's
charity many a times brother
and his people they just got this video
and they
he any any audacity to say that you know
the reason why i carried on the way i
did because plenty of people were paying
me lots of money
i never got good money brom and sisters
i don't get good money
i get i i just it's irrelevant if
someone's unjust i don't care if he's
getting the gold
uh or diamonds or he's not getting
nothing if someone's been unjust to
someone what's that got to do with
they're getting paid on it they're not
getting paid that's relevant to the
whole point you're being oppressed
yeah he's oh it's like me i don't know
slapping someone
um or something and then he gets angry
i'm like oh you're doing it because you
get
it's irrelevant what's that what to do
with anything if you've oppressed me
you've oppressed me it's irrelevant
i'm not getting paid i'm not getting
paid um like i said i'd
it's very sad if there's politics going
because of the charity sector and
they're trying to get one on each other
and you're throwing people under the bus
why is this it's disgraceful
if what you're seeing i'll take it from
what you're saying to me um
that's all i can say i don't charity
yeah yes no i i i i believe
like i said one of the best jobs it's
one of the best jobs
under the heavens to work for allah
azzawajal yeah
because when we die charities souther
kajar is going on forever yeah you know
and this is a legacy and i i know
brother sisters i do not
want this to be my downfall it's not i'm
going to keep going
and helping more souls and more servants
and help him more the dawah for allah
and his messenger
enchilada oh you should you should i
believe you know your job i believe
losing your job is absolutely unjust um
but promising says
i i interviewed uncle uh jawad uh to
bring you guys his take on it watch the
video
for yourself it's up to you um i'm here
just talking
matters from what's apparent and what we
can see
and to be just yeah i don't care if my
worst any music i'll be honest with you
if tommy robinson was sat here and he
went through that
that very specific thing that he went
through i would defend him
we don't our religion this is how our
religion works brother sisters it's not
i have a grudge again no it's wrong like
this guy tom robinson was in spain some
guy went and started insulting him in
his
family yeah it's that's where know i've
done a video recently i said i'm totally
against that
you're coming and insulting the guy i
don't he's made my worst enemy
but his kid is wrong wrong is wrong i'm
not gonna say that's tom robinson now
his family should get
i'm so sorry if it's wrong it's wrong
brother sisters that's inshallah from me
and uncle jamal inshallah
may allah bless you guys we ask you to
assume the best and make dua
for uncle jawad myself and brother
father's world may allah forgive him
for the statements that he made
inshallah and betray him inshallah until
next time assalamu alaykum